améliorer le quotidien des élèves et des
équipes pédagogiques grâce aux outils
numériques
en 2015 le département des yvelines a
investi plus de 30 millions d'euros pour
généraliser le très haut débit les
espaces numériques de travail ou encore
les tablettes dans les établissements
scolaires pourquoi le numérique c'est
pas simplement un outil pour mieux
apprendre mais c'est aussi pouvoir qu'au
décès pouvoir être le mieux armé dans un
monde où le digital est présent et voir
omniprésent au programme de ces
premières assises des moments d'échangé
de partage et d'expérience mais aussi
des ateliers thématiques comme
l'utilisation de robots dès le plus
jeune âge pour apprendre à lire
ces assises ont également été l'occasion
de pointer du doigt quelques
dysfonctionnements comme le manque de
formation des enseignants pour
l'utilisation des tablettes numériques
mais pas qu on observe aujourd'hui que
l'on discuté a touché des familles qui
sont des territoires socialement plus
défavorisés voilà pour nous ça c'est un
vrai enjeu c'est un enjeu convalescent
qui sont pas se poser dès demain c'est
une des difficultés de l'exercice
comment peut-on évaluer le fait qu'un
certain nombre d'élèves vont apprendre
plus facilement et obtenir de meilleurs
résultats
il faut se donner du temps pour pouvoir
avoir des résultats sur le volet
qualitatif des choses concernant le
volet quantitatif à la rentrée 2010 8
les élèves de 18 collèges yvelinois
seront dotés de tablettes numériques